[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation we did not
intend to match today but here we are
matching with our RR apparel Roxy
there's something we have to clear up
right away yes I know they're dating
they're dating but at least I sensed it
you sensed it I was late to picking up
on it and apparently they were dating
the entire time and we had no idea can
we watch them make out or what I don't
know I even worked on the edits I was
like I don't know where did I miss this
final piece of information if you're not
making out are you even dating that is
true depending on the age range anyway
we got five and six to go through so
ladies and gentlemen you know what to do
like this video leave down your thoughts
below of if you went to hell would you
try to be best friends with Satan also
subscribe and click that notification
get notifi when reaction for six is up
here on the
Chanel I have edited this one and also
full length Reaction watch along where
you sync up with your own copy available
for super sexy Rejects at our patreon
page thank you all been joying we
getting a lot of pledges from this show
I really appreciate it oh that's dope
dope so good it is so good gregas a good
day and hell baby let's go let's
go oh might be Satan dad beat
dad
Charlie that is the the best indicator
they're dating right there why am I why
are we feel like we watch your back feel
like it's so obvious I've been up all
night trying to figure out why the hotel
isn't working we've done trust Falls oh
my God I feel you girl we only have a
couple months left before the Angels
come home a beautiful mind but Satan
style maybe it's time no two ass don't
say it your dad the Lucifer he let the
extermination happen they just had a
meeting and said go ahead and kill
everyone I'm sure he had good reason
wait that's it kill everyone get me a
meeting with Heaven didn't we already
try that with Adam he was an but
a great musical number you got Daddy
Issues no we just have never been close
she of course has daddy issues he calls
only if he's bored or or like needs me
to do something daddy issues mhm that's
it almost there oh I have no idea what
Lucifer is going to be like
presenting the magic testicle back for
flipping rubber duck oh my God she's
more like him than we would
realize hold the Applause please okay
not what I've been picturing no not at
all daughter calling oh um uh hello
Charlie this is the most unexpected turn
ever especially after just watching Luci
has to be perfect hey
[Music]
you know where I am Dad I've told
you before you have oh well you know I
um I love his phone case just forgot you
know I've just been really busy you know
with um important things
oh he puts her off don't do this Dad
maybe you saw our commercial you know I
haven't been watching much TV lately
scrambles the brain what a trickster
kind of a big
ask yeah seems like a deadbeat but like
a nervous dead beat I need to speak to
heav I need to go to the top oh
no look dad I don't ask you for much I
never have but this love Alder
expressions in the background and I need
you they're behaving more like a couple
now I know I know inviting me over my
daughter wants to see me take that
depression mood this is such a choice
we are going to get this place
presentable and we are going to make an
amazing impression Vos I thought like
Charlie would be the odd duck which
she's so much like her dad you could see
how they're father and daughter
Charlie hey Dad oh it's so good to see
you and yet she's so off-put by him the
apple on his hat is
hysterical he's even shorter than her
that must mean that Lilith is tall girl
wow this place sure looks uh uh-huh
uh-huh cookies falling oh what in the
Unholy hell is that oh he's judgmental
add a bit of color don't you think and
you are Alister the one doing your daddy
job you are much shorter in real life
it's a purposeful choice I was just
saying people tell me that all the time
I guess that's why Charlie called it the
hasb been
Hotel it was actually my idea well it's
not very clever oh f you
Zing good one without aliser we wouldn't
have been able to pretty it up this much
give Alistair the respect he deserves
I'm waiting for Alistair to really mess
up I am happy to fulfill her bizarre
request so far alistair's been awesome
thank you
Alistair we're all very proud of her is
he going to ask for his like think he's
trying to show to the dad he's closer
with her than the dad is this is vaggie
she's my girlfriend they just establish
their boyfriend and girlfriend I mean
girlfriend and girlfriend hello I
clean nicely
done all right
then oh here we go looks like you could
use some help from the big boss of Hell
himself oh my God great with a punch of
a this feels
like totally we can't be seeing the
whole thing right now you know you get
the family right thanks D who needs a
bus boy now that you've got the
chef yeah you see it coming out of him
having a bus boy doesn't eliminate
having the chef those are two very
different jobs who's been here since day
one see who makes you chuckle with an
old timey pun your executive producer oh
remember when I fix that CL today's
trying to get thank you sir you what is
his motive he's competing but for what
exactly done that I wish that I had what
it's a little funny you could almost
call me dad
oh
and remember him and Lilith were
gone for the same amount of time I've
always thought Lilith sent him or
something happened there true violin
versus the pianos they say when you're
looking for
assistance pick the PA of least
resistance good job in your
needy no substitute for
Pure they say the family you choose is
better what a bunch of losers you B out
of my song yeah singing it I'll finish
it oh you tacky piece of yes it's me
what what a GU a while
but oh my
god did you know she was coming
no who oh oh thought it was L me too so
you two know each other oh yeah we go
way back ran in the same circles when we
were alive oh interesting that's the
first time we've seen that right right
actually indicated towards it your
highness you got to warn a girl when
she's in mixed company Charmed I'm sure
like it's so interesting how they've
done him where can a girl get a drink
around
here my my is that Husker really feels
like a saloon how you been furball good
until 5 minutes ago yeah Savage get him
what you been up to girly fighting bugs
and uh how's that going for you they're
winning but not for long yeah get him
Nifty he's been here a while and is
still a big creepy mystery what's his
deal he appeared in Hell suddenly Making
a Splash quicker than anyone had ever
seen I could see that wanted to dismiss
him soon Overlord start going miss him
bars no one knew what happened to him
until these strange radio broadcast
started going out I love the oldtime
radio aesthetic do you think somehow
he's working for the atams of the world
maybe but Underneath It
All he's a total sweetie poor a couple
thinkers a Ry and he becomes a
kitten he just got an ego and pride you
don't want to wrong him once we have the
proof that Redemption is possible this
whole hotel will be full of demons oh my
God he just doesn't believe in her
you've been gone a while and it's not
like anybody knows why and don't you
worry your fuzzy head about it what is
Big Talk for someone who's also on
leash
yeah what did you
say nothing I um oh no I don't like
when husk is scared I will tear your
soul apart and broadcast your screams
for every other disrespectful Rich Jesus
I am so interested in Alistair always
nice to catch up what is up who's leash
is he on is it Lilith but when you're
gone for seven years in hell I mean that
feels like such a short amount of time s
years in Hell well it's a blip on the
radar but where'd you go there's nowhere
to go like they must have thought he was
one of the ones they killed look I love
that you want to see the best in people
but these Sinners you know they're just
the worst Heaven is not exactly as
carefree as you might think messed up
our people are awful they got gifted
Free Will and look what they did with it
everything's terrible feel like I
recognize his voice people like jeez
what now well like that bibsy we know
you're in
ah she's dodging these guys I may be in
trouble with some lone
shocks actual literal interpretation you
build something nice you invite people
in and offer them everything and they
just bring violence and Chaos that's
exactly what happens to real rejects
who'd that happen with
Greg I don't want to embarrass you on
camera a reminder to all not to mess
with the radio demon he is the
coolest jeez jeez he's almost what I
would have thought Lucifer would have
been though Sinners are violent
Psychopaths hell bent on causing as much
pain and destruction as they can so
that's what warrants you to get in Hell
defending this hotel it may be a bit
more sadistic but he's doing it for me
how come he have in but my own father
can't right sorry about the mess but I'm
sure the little bug can take care of it
got to get out of her I think you should
go Mimsy yeah you don't actually give a
about this tacky place do you don't
you dare you need to leave have fun with
your little princess and your little
hotel see if I can what is alistair's
motive can't I can't figure it out
whoever's leash he's on is why he's here
doing this Heaven never listens they
didn't listen to me they won't listen to
you oh my god valid baby he was a fallen
angel didn't
know but maybe she doesn't know
fullys sing it baby he tried now you're
the
only fighting
for you hav't been you haven't been
fighting for
[Music]
her it's got a great
voice where you been this whole time
when I I was young I didn't really know
you at all a baby Charlie the red cheeks
on a baby is so cute but I heard your
stories looks like
[Music]
Joker what's with the
duckies she's so much like
him
Lilith was tall they gave her no
face just for this memory
yeah they were like we're not ready to
choose or does she even remember what
she looks like I need to
[Music]
save why do you care about them so much
looks like the Apple doesn't
fall I've missed that smile alistair's
not going to like this or is this
alistair's plan push
[Music]
this
whoa like this is father daughter song
is
great you don't get like that look
at these circus
performers who would have thought you
get such a touching song
Lucifer see aliser is watching with a
smile aliser always has a smile will you
be okay I'll be fine that's my
girl the piano medley you ready I'm
ready cuz you'll be with me my
girlfriend cuz we're lovers in
heaven
yay oh boy that one felt like the
shortest one yet even though it's the
exact same runtime yeah just it flew
these episodes flew lie they do they
mostly because the show is sick I'm not
shooting this part later I'm shooting
this in the immediate moment cuz say hey
guys thanks for everyone who bought a
bunch of shirts from reject naations
shop.com in the year 2023 it continues
to do so in 2024 Roxy showed wearing
this tea and I was like yes I was also
wearing this tea and I said I could
change into one of the many that we own
but I think it'd be funny if we both
wore the same t-shirt and the joke was
hilarious could not stop laughing guys
there are so many shirts that we have
and each one you get is a wonderful
contribution to the Chanel I'm grateful
that everyone who re B if you already
bought one thank you buy yourself
another if you haven't bought one what
are you doing I don't care if your bank
accounts in the negatives go more
negative it'll be for a good cause it's
an investment in your
comfort what's more important than that
that's why I'm in debt to Sony massage
parlers anyway guys uh thank you so much
and um hey you know what if I do a crop
in I'm just going to
continue I was going to say to for the
review kicking off what was the first
thing I said uh in episode here it is
that was a surprise that was real
surprised I thought he'd be the most
like intimidating imposing one but he's
a sensitive Angel sensitive Fallen Angel
and I like the approach to him because
uh you know usually Lucifer's portrayed
as like the bad boy right and they
really leaned into he was an Angel who
didn't like the way heaven was being run
and they've been building up Heaven at
you have have you seen the show
Supernatural parts of it oh wow you're
not a TV girl CW Show with the brother
there's like 45 Seasons you haven't seen
any of it parts of it okay well I'm on
season 13 right now oh my God no way and
they're I don't want to it's really good
it's the one that I with the two
brothers right yeah yeah Jensen knackles
and J P um and the there's an element
that comes in pretty really on and stay
throughout the show about heaven and
they they do have a sim a thing there
where they portray Heaven I was like
Angels aren't so good you know they you
can't really trust these guys and they
have a some strict rules and and it
was the first time I saw something that
was really showing oh yeah Heaven's
always portrayed as like this beautiful
Pleasant Phil but man they must be as
heavy enforcers and what I liked with
the Lucifer portrayal was he seemed like
a guy who didn't like the way perhaps
the draconian ways go down in heaven and
was trying to find and was trying to
lean into the Free Will aspect and help
out uh with like the people on Earth and
stuff but then this came to be like the
way he the way he lamented about uh to
Charlie with like look we gave these
people Free Will and now look what they
turn into like he had good intentions he
wasn't just a troublemaker and I I find
that to be really surprising and it
makes sense because I always thought
Charlie was just ah you're the odd duck
you know in the family you just happen
to turn out to be this like great caring
woman but your dad's the evil of all
evils and apparently not well the way
that they depicted him in the pilot
though we knew he wasn't going to be the
evil of all evils I felt I felt you know
it's actually the first episode not the
pilot no in the pilot the first episode
when they do the backstory oh no I
thought it was in the pilot when we hear
when we hear about the fact that he was
the Fallen Angel and they first
mentioned that she was the daughter of
Lucifer and Lilith and we hear a little
bit about it it was episode one wrong
scene I don't want to embarrass you
there was no mention of Lucifer and the
pilot there was but not that backstory
and I don't want to put you to shame
what did they say in the pilot they just
mentioned that she's the daughter of
Lucifer I'm not talking about that
visual imagery from the first
episode well I I I'm pretty sure it was
in the I'm pretty sure because that's
how whatever anyway uh I don't I I just
want you to feel comfortable when you're
here to express yourself why are you
what's going on on right now what are
you
doing anyway uh I don't know what I was
going to say now I don't feel shamed I
feel uh empty-headed confused no you
were saying you were saying that in the
pilot first episode one of them that
Lucifer was
portrayed I never thought he was gonna
be evil or a bad guy because that's not
who Lucifer is um but I did I didn't
think he was going to be so bumbling
like in this he is he seems like out of
it weirdo I you kept saying how similar
they were I spit on you you kept saying
how similar they were I didn't see them
to be similar really uh at first because
the state that we find him in he seems
like a like Spacey you call him a dead
be like just out of it doesn't really
care about anything just like in a in a
depressed hole and it kind of made me
think when did that turn take because
then we just heard this backstory from
him that he also tried this and at what
and we see him carrying her when she's a
kid but now we know they're kind of a
strange she talked to him five months
ago at what point then was he like F
this I'm out I can't keep
trying I have no idea when that point
would be I think what I was saying dead
beat it was more that he feels like he
was a failure and I I feel like the
episode really demonstrated that
throughout that and then when you get to
that song when he's saying I tried I
there's this impression you get that
like I want to unpack like what the lore
and the Really the the lineages of how
Hell turned into what it is now for
Lucifer to end up here because people
are still you know he's still revered
the The Legend the myth of Lucifer is
still talked about no one just sees him
and goes what a joke you know you yeah
that was a smart device when mit's like
is that Lucifer because we know like the
even strangers are like oh my God I'm in
the room with mixed company yeah yeah
it's a it's a fun way to do it what I am
wanting uh from there's a lot of other
good things that happened in this
episode the one thing that I did that
did dawn on me here uh when it comes to
Charlie's motivation to help these
people she keeps calling them my people
and I haven't unless I'm completely
missing something I haven't really
gotten a sense of any part of the
community that feels like it's worth
fighting like when she says my people I
I I'm like why do you care about these
people so much like I you I never see
her connect with any one outside of
who's at this hotel immediately never
see her with a sense of community never
get any of that to want to be like yeah
you should go help but she people she
feels a kinship to them because she is
the princess of hell and we see it from
the beginning when she goes and she is
on that talk show and she announces the
hasbin hotel and while people aren't
treating her well she still knows that
it's her job to try and help them live
the best lives and also she I think she
feels like they've been given a bad hand
they're getting
executed and she's seen we when we do
see her with her girlfriend or with
aliser who has such a bad rep but she's
taking him in or with um angel dust like
there's so much good in the in between
moments and I think she's seeing that
but you're right we haven't seen her
like there's been no like parade through
the masses and I would like to see her
with more people to kind of see how they
read her we did see early on her go
through the streets remember yeah but
there was no that first song yeah we
didn't see the dynamic of the people to
her like I don't know how everybody
feels about her yeah no one likes her
yeah yeah it would be nice to see like
is that just that part of Hell or like
there outskirts of hell that are rooting
for her you know yeah that's the one one
part I'm craving I'm not saying like
it's not within the world is something I
just would like to see it's a it's akin
to when you watch like a superhero thing
and you go well I want to see like the
superhero save some people so that way I
get a sense of like that's what really
helps it feel heroic and when it's
specifically I'm specifically talking
about the lines of these are our people
my people and I don't see that
connection that that's the one part but
I but it doesn't really matter honestly
I'm kind of like getting hung up on
something that's larger than yeah that's
interesting it's working for me because
I feel like that's what she's the entire
point of the hotel is that she's looking
for the people to come there she wants
them like to want to get help but I do
hear you it was it's also Wilding my
feelings apprciate it's wild to go from
episode four to episode 5 that was I
mean just totally just such a different
shift is this season done at six I think
so so this was the penultimate episode
yeah I think so that's crazy I need this
to be a longer season right right and
that's why I'm I'm thinking about some
things that I'm wondering if we will get
them but as but with what we got here at
least we got you know the
confirmation that vaggie and uh Charlie
her I know I was like man they never
make it clear in this episode we're girl
we're dating aren't you in bed with me
we're this is my girlfriend well they
really laid it out for anyone who might
have been a little lost but imagine if
we hadn't dropped our first few episodes
and had seen all the comments of people
being like that's girl their girlfriend
and girlfriend and then we just got this
we were like what yeah it's true well um
and then the last couple things aliser
we're g to find out hopefully find out
next episode what his true motivation
really is I think he I want to say he's
my favorite character he is definitely
my favorite character just because I've
never seen anything like this where I do
not trust him but I love him and I'm
going to be so disappointed in him when
he neverly lets us down and we find out
who his master really is or whose leash
he's on well he's always in such control
and he just resists to go all out like
he loves a toy with his food at all
times he could easily just probably snap
his fing fingers and be done with people
but he he he he likes to let things just
in he has some ultimate plan but yet
someone else has power over him which I
think is a smart thing to do for your
character I don't know what's going to
on with him but it seems it's quite
intriguing because hus did talk about
him being on a leash but he was he was
having the whole thing with uh Lucifer
of I I did not pick up on all at all
about him you know viewing Charlie like
his own daughter and when that song came
in I couldn't tell that's just some
manipulation ploy to push re h on her I
was like who at first I thought he was
hitting on her I was like I don't know
what's happening right now cuz it kind
of came out of nowhere to me the last
thing I expect I that to me I I don't I
did not see that coming at all and I
feel like he was manipulating a
situation otherwise I think he would
have been more upset or they would have
shown him being upset after the
fatherdaughter
duet um final song that we got I think
it is possible I just I think that so
far he's had full free range over ruling
Charlie in this hotel and he knows that
when her dad comes in he's not the dad
and that Lucifer can really change
things your instincts are better than
mine I thought vaggie was just his her
friend so you know and maybe you might
be right there might be some master plan
here by aliser to get her and Lucifer
close and by making Lucifer jealous
aliser thought okay Lucifer's going to
then introduce her to the heavens that's
that's what I was think definely
possible yeah but you don't need to
appease my weak man emotions I know what
you're doing you're just trying to make
me feel all right about how I feel when
you know you're right it's okay no I
think it is possible it's okay all right
look I don't need to be plated to I
don't need to be I need to talk down to
me a little Sensi I'm not I'm not no I'm
not not sensitive no it's I'm a big boy
it's lighter than sensitive it's sensey
sensei's cute a so
sensey I can do 30 push-ups in a row I
know I can see your
let's go cheee I drink energy drinks I
drink energy I drink g- fuel uh I think
you're crashing it my dude hasb been
hotel that's what's up anyway guys we're
done with this one anyway my dudes we're
done with this one and we'll see you for
episode six which is the finale of
hasbin hotel if you're not there then
you're Square
bro Rox has been a workshop in this
character yeah
and this is what four years of
Groundlings will
[Music]
get